[Applaudissements]
ça y est enfin on croit
et vous est-ce que vous me croyez
ou plutôt est-ce que vous m'auriez cru
il y a 5 ans si je vous avais dit que je
voulais faire de la mécanique
j'entends souvent la même phrase en ce
moment ça ressemble à un mais si ta
tenue jusqu'ici oui je veux bien croire
que tu veux vraiment faire de la
mécanique si tu es toujours là ouais je
te crois autrement dit il faut 4 ou 5
ans pour être prise au sérieux
c'était pas prémédité je me suis pas
posé de questions je me suis pas demandé
si ce monde était prêt à m'accueillir et
très vite j'ai dû me rendre à l'évidence
et ça est-ce que vous le croyez quand
j'ai trouvé mon premier stage j'ai pris
rendez-vous chez mon délégué à l'école
pour qu'ils signent mon contrat
un rendez-vous qui devait juste se
limiter à ça c'est transformant en une
discussion de plus d'une heure où j'ai
dû le convaincre de mes choix et de oui
pourquoi j'étais sûre de vouloir faire
ça et que oui je voulais vraiment faire
de la mécanique et que j'étais pas là
pour rire
ensuite ce stage c'est très mal passé on
voulait pas que je porte la salopette on
me disait que ma place était pas dans
l'atelier mais à la réception pendu au
téléphone
donc j'ai été rapporté cette histoire à
ce même délégué et le plus drôle c'est
que juste après il m'a recommandé auprès
d'un autre garage en tant que
réceptionniste
avoue que c'est risible
vous l'aurez donc compris c'est seul que
j'ai appris à naviguer dans ce milieu
scolaire puis professionnel j'ai dû
apprendre à réagir quand il le fallait à
me battre pour mes objectifs et à pas me
laisser décourager
mais je vous avoue que parfois c'est
difficile
vous en connaissez beaucoup vous des
femmes mécaniciennes
moi toutes les personnes que je
rencontre dans mon métier sont des
hommes que je sois chez mon marchand de
pièces à la casse automobile à mon
boulot avec mes collègues ou une
majorité des clients je suis entourée
par la gente masculine du matin au soir
vous me direz mais qu'est-ce que ça
change
mais en fait le manque de représentation
implique des choses pour moi auxquelles
j'avais pas pensé
par exemple je me sens plus vulnérable
et exposé au préjugés au micro-agression
je sais pas toujours vers qui me
tournait quand un premier un problème
lié à mon genre fait surface
selon moi les liens sociaux commerciaux
et professionnels sont plus difficiles à
nouer prennent plus de temps je reviens
à hongrois parfois il faut 4 ans
mais le plus difficile je pense que
c'est d'être en hyper vigilance d'être
dans l'analyse et l'interprétation à
chaque nouvelle personne que je
rencontre de me demander si cette
personne me juge mens plane prend en
compte mes compétences de mécanicienne
ou pas du tout
pardon
mais pardon
mais compétences de mécaniciennes ou pas
du tout moi aucune femme ne m'a dit que
je devrais me battre pour ma salopette
et prouver que je mérite ma salopette et
plus le temps passe plus j'ai
l'impression que malgré toute leur bonne
volonté les hommes quand on ne
comprendront jamais par quoi je passe
j'ai personne pour me dire si ce que je
vis est normal ou complètement toxique
malheureusement je partage pas cette
passion avec mon réseau féminin mes amis
ne font pas de mécanique elle s'y
intéressent pas et je pense que je perds
vite leur attention quand je leur dis
que j'ai eu du mal à purger un circuit
d'embrayage ou que je me rappelle pas
avoir serré le tendeur mobile d'une
courroie
sur le terrain aussi j'ai dû mettre des
choses en place parce que si je fais pas
ça je suis moins performante évidemment
que je suis moins performante quand je
reçois une remarque sexiste dans la
journée quand par exemple je demande ce
qui reste à faire et qu'on me dit pour
rigoler il reste de la vaisselle ça fait
rire qui ou quand j'ai quelque chose de
lourd en main et qu'on me dit il est où
l'homme pour t'aider
ou simplement quand tu sais pas si un
client va répondre à ton bonjour ou
juste dévisager
je suis pas toujours à l'aise mais
parfois je me force à réagir mais c'est
vrai que c'est plus facile de laisser
couler que déconstruire quotidiennement
les discours
en parlant de laisser couler mon
calendrier berner vous savez très bien
de quoi je parle vous connaissez la
version avec les femmes c'est celui que
je vois tous les matins en arrivant au
boulot il y a celui avec les hommes je
lui ai trouvé une place dans l'atelier
il a parfois disparu souvent été
retournée et depuis le 1er janvier je
l'ai plus jamais revu évidemment le leur
a recommencé son tour
clairement il y a un déséquilibre et
même si j'en fais pas ma mission
principale je pense que c'est mon devoir
d'apporter ma pâte pour une profession
plus juste
par exemple je pense à mes amis ou les
amis de mes amis qui se font souvent
prendre pour des idiotes dans les
garages et je sais que quand elles ont
mon numéro elles hésitent pas à
m'appeler pour un conseil ou juste une
vérification de ce qu'un garagiste
masculin leur aurait dit et pour moi
c'est une manière de rétablir cet
équilibre c'est une manière de faire de
ce qu'on considère une faiblesse au
quotidien une force dans ces moments de
solidarité féminine
d'ailleurs cette solidarité féminine je
l'applique aussi dans ma vie privée en
règle générale je fais de mon temps
libre un espace SAF dédié à la sororité
un espace
par exemple pour moi pour évacuer mes
journées c'est plus facile de le faire
avec des hommes pardon avec des femmes
c'est beaucoup plus facile pour moi de
les évacuer avec des femmes ou par
exemple je me suis laissé à la pole
dance en espérant y trouver une majorité
de femmes
et sur le lieu de travail aussi j'ai dû
rendre mon environnement plus
accueillant
par exemple je me suis battu pour avoir
un vesti à moi où j'ai été patiente
quand ma salopette était trop grande
et j'aimerais proposer une formation de
sensibilisation sexisme dans les milieux
professionnels
je sais que ce sont des demandes
légitimes même si peu conventionnelles
pour eux
et si eux minimise l'impact de certains
détails moi pas une voix pas l'urgence
moi je la vis au quotidien
et l'accès à certaines commodités qui
peut paraître triviale pour eux et en
fait challengeant pour moi
après vous l'avez compris pardon
je sais plus ce que tu dis ou pas mais
comme vous l'avez compris je suis
toujours là après cinq ans et c'est
grâce à toutes ces choses que j'ai pu
mettre en place et c'est parce que
j'aime vraiment mon boulot que je suis
toujours là parce que j'adore quand une
voiture arrive avec une odeur insolite
ou un bruit étrange et
parce que je vous parle même pas de la
satisfaction que c'est quand c'est
réparé
et je sais que quand je repense à ce
parcours sans les obstacles bah
évidemment ça me semble plus joli plus
simple mais je sais que
ces événements sont là
et je les oublie pas
heureusement dans toute cette masse
d'hommes j'ai quand même réussi à
trouver des mentors et des personnes de
confiance des gens avec qui je me sens
pas à part c'est des personnes avec qui
j'avance et qui veulent me voir avancer
et qui m'aident à affronter ce parcours
de la combattante
mais j'ai eu le choix que ce soit des
hommes
il y a 5 ans on m'a pas cru mais la
prochaine fois qu'une femme vient vous
parler en salopette s'il vous plaît
croyez là merci pour elle merci
[Applaudissements]